you're having so much fame so much
success are you getting I heard you were
getting offers of endorsements yeah I
truly you're getting endorsements and
I'm just curious well come on in urban
yeah what kind of endorsement
well vape pens first of all which is
that true so in my brand yeah and but
the ones I get I get a lot of lesbians
in that one little lesbian organizations
that want me to endorse things and like
no I don't want to be the face of your
dildo in the shape of a dolphin but
thank you is that a real Prada I'm not
kidding why would you need it in the
shape of a door I don't know why would I
not send them to me
I got Fridays free you mean the
endorsement or the actual dildo oh the
endorse I mean I gotta say I like this
god this show is not going to air sorry
I'm gonna be putting a satellite and sat
in his face did they really offer you
it's pretty dull I didn't like I'm you
know when I'm with a girl what I want to
do is strap on Charlie to tuna you know
flipper go get fun
hey settle down karna alright is this
Christ the hell's going on here you are
a little attracted though admit it yes I
am
you